- no lying no I don't say sorry and no
perfect but I'm are you living your
dream you work on something for so long
like I mean some of these songs I've
been working on for like a year and a
half kind of thing and to finally have
it out in the world and let people get a
chance to listen to it and enjoy it and
have people connect to it it's just like
it's the best that's how I know I'm
living my dream garnering attention and
over 10 million views on YouTube with
this 2013 hit everywhere we go Canadian
hip-hop artist son reals first
full-length album one long dream is out
now but the road to success wasn't easy
you are very open about your own
struggles yeah you talked about your
depression throughout your closet last
year No how important was it to have
music part of your life at the moment
the most important thing ever I mean
yeah when I lost my father literally the
day I went on tour I had like 30 dates I
had to do and I got the news from my mom
and like I literally just kind of went
on the road right after did shows and
everything and it was really music that
got me through it
it's not problems on so many different
levels was it difficult for you to write
down the words of your life and create
that video and release that song it is
difficult to write songs like that is
difficult to be honest putting yourself
out there to the world can be scary and
you know I try to do the best job I can
with just being honest with it and kind
of being like maybe if I say this maybe
somebody else won't feel though maybe
somebody else will relate that's what I
always turn to music for and to be able
to do the same thing for other people is
huge everybody's got some problems